امك بك. هل تعطف الجزائر على
اوروبا لتحميهم من شتاء بوتين
تظهر هنا كرئيسة جديدة لبريطانيا
فكيف ستكون ردة فعل موسكو? هل
عشرة الاف هجمة نفذتها الوكالة
الامريكية خلال السنوات الاخيرة.
لبحث ضمان حصص اكبر من واردات
الغاز الجزائري الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي تملق اوروبي للجزائر
بهدف الحصول على القليل من الدفئ
الفنية والسياسية. وفي العراق
ايضا نشر مقطع فيديو بقوة عبر
الجزائرية. في يوم واحد وحفل
زفاف واحد شاب جزائري يتزوج
التصعيد والعنف. واعلنت في بيان
تشكيل فريق فني لوضع خريطة طريق
اردوغان ضد اليونان عدائية ويجب
ان تتوقف. اما اردوجان فقد سخر
تشير الى ان الجيش الروسي يعاني
نقصا حادا في الامدادات
امريكا. الاحداث والتطورات.
الاتحاد الاوروبي تصريحات
بدعم جهود التهدئة وتنقية
الاجواء بين القوى الوطنية ومنع
وحتى اللحظة لم ترد الادارة
الامريكية على هذه الاتهامات
الرسالة العسكرية يا ابناء العم
سام? بريطانيا تتحضر. بينما
اتهمت وكالة الامن القومي
الامريكي بشن هجمات سيبرانية ضد
بالاف بي اي يصرح جهاز
لاستخبارات الصيني يعد اكثر
كفاءة وذكاء وخطورة من ان يتم
ولكن كان لبكين رأي اخر. حيث
جامعة الصينية المختصة بابحاث
الطيران والفضاء ضمن اكثر من
ينتابني احساس ان رأسك هذا
سينفجر بطلقة قناص قبل ان تنفجر
الصحيفة تنقل عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان المشتريات
بمحافظة نيسان العراقية متلبسا
بالرشوة. لقد وجدنا متولي النسخة
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي لعملية
القبض على مدير الامن الوطني
في الجنوب ومرتفعة في دونيتسك.
المجلس الاوروبي يزور الجزائر
قبل خمسة عشر عاما نقل مفاعل
نووي سوري باستخدام طائراته
امرأتين في الوقت نفسه ما اثار
ضجة في الشارع الجزائري. يا فرحة
بالوناتك? يظهر هنا المجنون ولكن
في اوكرانيا. صحيفة نيويورك
باوكرانيا واضافت الصحيفة ان
عمليات الشراء تظهر ان بدأت تؤثر
سانك هاك وهو منشق كوري شمالي
تحول الى ناشط ان البالونات التي
الحدود المتوترة على الرغم من
تحذير كوريا الشمالية الاخير من
البريطاني لاوكرانيا كما كان في
عهد جونسون? اختراق حدودي.
الحربية. في العراق اوصت الجلسة
الثانية لمؤتمر الحوار الوطني
لمواجهة عاصفة الشتاء القادمة.
زعم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انه دمر
على روسيا. ليظهر ترامب بدوره
مادحا الرئيسين الصيني شي جين
لحل الازمة. ودعا المؤتمر التيار
الصدري للمشاركة في الاجتماعات
الحكومة الجديدة كي تدخل
المباراة السياسية. والهدف
تايمز الامريكية ووفق مصادر
استخباراتية روسيا تعتزم شراء
لمنصبه. ولكن مهلا هناك شيء
متغير بشكله. نعم لقد استخدم
وهي التي توعدت باستخدام نووي مع
روسيا اذا وصلت لهذا المنصب. وها
انها تسلقت لتصل اليه بجدارة
وتكون الاجدر بحمل لقب المرأة
بينغ والروسي فلاديمير بوتين
وواصفا بايدن بانه رئيس في تاريخ
عشرون بالونا ضخما تحمل لافتة
مناهضة لكوريا الشمالية عبر
ملايين من القذائف المدفعية
والصاروخية من كوريا الشمالية.
خاصة اليورو الذي يشهد موتا
سريريا بسبب العقوبات المفروضة
من الغرب ولمح لحرب ضد احدى دول
الناتو محذرا اليونان قائلا فجأة
بدلا من الدولار واليورو وهي
ضربة اقتصادية للعملات الغربية
يمكننا ان نأتي بين ليلة وضحاها.
زمن استعدنا السيطرة على بلدتين
الخطيرة. وكانت شركة جاز برو
الروسية العملاقة للطاقة اعلنت
الكلام صحيح برأيكم? الصين تحت
الاختراق. اطلق عليها بلد
كمامة وعشرات الالاف من اقراص
تايلينول وفيتامين سي. لماذا
في قدرة روسيا على الاستمرار في
حربها على اوكرانيا. هل هذا
ان الصين ستبدأ تسديد ثمن شحنات
الغاز الروسي بالروبل واليوان
المليار جاسوس وسط اتهامات
باختراقات سيبرانية هنا مسؤول
ومن المكاتب المرموقة الى
القنبلة الموقوتة محطة النووية.
الجوية الملكية في فرفورد
بانجلترا. وحلقتا فوق شرق البحر
المتوسط وشبه الجزيرة العربية
والبحر الاحمر فما الهدف من هذه
طويلة المدى ذات قدرات نووية فوق
الشرق الاوسط في استعراض للقوة
ضمن احداث مهمة من نوعها في
المنطقة. وذلك مع استمرار التوتر
مسيرة اوكرانية على محطة
النووية. وعلى ذكر هذه الكلمة
هجوم مميت بسبب انشطة التي تقوم
بها كوريا الجنوبية. واوضح بارك
تم اطلاقها من بلدة حدودية في
كوريا الجنوبية حملت عشرين الف
الجيش الامريكي يصرح انه اطلق
قاذيفتين من طراز وهي قاذفات
ثمانية عاما طالبت بانهاء
الملكية في بريطانيا لتشعل نيران
للجنون فنون. دعونا نتخلص من كيم
جونغ اون واخته كيم يو جونغ
جونسون يودع الرئاسة بممر شرفي
لتدخله ليزيتراس من اوسع ابوابه
الاستخبارات الروسية تلقي القبض
على جاسوس غربي حسب وصفهم واتهم
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تصرح ان
قواتها احبطت هجوما بطائرات
الامريكيين في البيت الابيض يجب
ان يتم تصنيف روسيا كدولة راعية
معالجة اخطاء بوريس جونسون
السابقة. وها هو يلقي خطاب وداعه
المشط لاول مرة في حياته. فقد
كان يظهر هكذا وهكذا. وهكذا.
برأيكم. هل ستستطيع ان تقف
للكرملين? وهل سيستمر الدعم
للارهاب. ليرد بايدن لا يجب ان
نصنف روسيا كدولة راعية للارهاب.
هي اليوم تتربع على عرشه فهل تفي
بوعدها? ولا ننسى انها قبل
اوروبا تخرج للشارع وتطالب
بالعكس. وذلك بعدما اغلق بوتين
ولماذا يا هذا? ليتكرر السؤال
مرة اخرى ومن صحفي في البيت
الغضب في قلب الملكة اليزابيث.
فهل هذا المنصب ثمن لسكوتها ام
ايفان سافرونوفا المتخصص في
الشؤون العسكرية بنقل اسرار
الاتحاد الاوروبي. ومن صرخات
المتظاهرين الى صراخ المشرعين
صنابير وتكون البداية من التشيك
باكثر من سبعين الف متظاهر.
الكبير منهم والصغير يحمل علم
روسيا. الشعب التشيكي يهتف. هذه
سجن شديد الحراسة. ولا ننسى ان
بوتين كان جاسوسا قبل ان يكون
المانيا وايطاليا وفرنسا.
تظاهرات وانتقادات لا ضد عقوبات
الروسي الى الاستخبارات
الالمانية. ليقول القضاء الروسي
بين واشنطن وموسكو وطهران. حيث
اقلعت القاذفتان من قاعدة القوات
عسكرية روسية الى المخابرات
التشيكية ومعلومات عن الجيش
الحرب ليست حربا. الاسعار في
ارتفاع والضرائب ترتفع. وفواتير
الاوروبيون عض قلبي ولا تعض
رغيفي. كان الهدف خنق الاقتصاد
الحديدية. فهل هذا اللقب كفيل
بجعلها تقف امام عقلية بوتين
الجزائر والاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ينشر فيديو لقصفه مفاعل نووي في
السياسية المحنكة؟ الملكة
اليزابيث تكلف اليزا ترانس تشكيل
الروسي حتى يخرج الشعب وينقلب
على بوتين. واليوم ها هي شعوب
كوريا الشمالية تتعرض للاختراق.
واردوغان يهدد حلف الناتو. فهل
رئيسا. ومن معارك الاستخبارات
الى معارك تكسير العظام. قالها
الابيض ويقول هاب للصحفيين مرة
اخرى لا وذلك وفقا لوكالة رويترز
قاذفة النووية تحلق في اجواء
الشرق الاوسط. خيانة روسية.
هي الخيانة? الصين تطلق مشروع
المليار واوروبا تطلب الرحمة من
الكهرباء في تزايد مرعب. الاصوات
تعلو اكثر ليصل صداها الى
بوتين يطلق صقره ليلتقط فريسته.
نعم بتهمة الخيانة العظمى
كلمة وينطق القاضي حكمه عليه
بالسجن لمدة اثنين وعشرين عاما.
تظهر بالمرأة الحديدية لمواجهة
فلاديمير بوتين. بينما حدود
هذه الدولة العربية والعراق في
انتظار مفتاح الحل السياسي بينما
اكثر من ست دول اوروبي. وبايدن
يرفض طلبا اوكرانيا وبريطانيا
ستكون للاحسن ام للاسوأ برأيكم?
فريسة غربية تقع في يد بوتين
وحلفاء روسيا يظهرون للعلن في